scene 1 07 take one common mark well
I've been working here at the kodak
theatre for many many years i was
working here when it was called the
polaroid theater and the daguerreotype
theater i suppose in 150 years i'll be
in the thought shapes theater or perhaps
i'll be on the street i do never refer
to yourself as Academy Award winner
Kevin Kline Oh others can do that
everyone I just say hi I'm Kevin you
can't do it can you imac hang I can do
you haven't accepted it now you accept
the trophy you must accept your place in
life you are royal hi I'm Academy Award
winner Kevin Kline was that so hard yes
hey sounded very phony your dentures my
driver is getting impatient I have to
leave if you do not take care of your
Oscar your Oscar will not take care of
you it can turn into your best friend or
your worst enemy they can turn into the
proverbial candlestick in the library
with Colonel Mustard yes I've been told
I look like Oscar except Oscar doesn't
have this strained whisper hair you know
I cut it every day my seven o'clock he
gets this long it's my seven o'clock
shadow I like to call it keep the thumb
below the bum again beat the thumb below
the bun right again only this time
they're I'm beautiful and I have a
secret I'm beautiful died of a secret
hey there keep the thumb below the bomb
this time like Michael Kay keep the
thumb below depim we don't consider him
to be an oscar abuser he was an oscar
miss user it's a big difference and I
think that line of demarcation involves
body cavities here's the snickers fun
size oh sorry crushed nuts welcome Oscar
cannot have chocolate and this oscar has
had a balanced meal and has done his
homework I knew that then the rules in I
ain't changing them nor fool you what's
that Oscar yes you're not studying hard
enough I'm so
right I am I am do you think I do this
for my own health I don't know do you I
do actually I haven't had a drop of
drink since wings the silent film not
the television show although the idea of
a small town airport is brilliant I mean
imagine the possibilities for example
fog what does one do when one is a small
town airport boggles the mind by George
I think you've got it happy you're home
pairs up well look at you girl y'all
heads up you're all girls up look at you
you're all Oscar was there the good
times that Oscar was there in the bad
times and Oscar was there when I was
founded a pool of my own vomit and Oscar
was there when I was crying saying I
don't love you I don't love you and I
was looking into the mirror
you